let's talk Tori Spelling for a minute
here because she had news that we'll
have all you die hard 902 uh no fans on
high alert altogether
no no Twitter I do want to get an update
have you heard anything about taking it
to somewhere else even just the two of
you ladies together nothing I know we
wish to gone on longer but you know what
October actually is the 30-year reunion
of the day the Pertino premieres and yes
Jenny and I do have something else in
the work and we're in pre-production and
decades after this iconic West Beverly
battle cry
you
in my beauty BS competition show
celebrity show-off airing tonight on TBS
I now pronounce you husband and wife all
I was hearing from people on line was
I'm missing my wedding postponed I
actually am an ordained minister so I
was like you know what let's try
virtually married someone and we did it
the episodes are all self shot so Tori &
Dean's five kids joined the crew yeah
100% my family they were the producers
directors craft service makeup
everything we did it all their family
has grown even bigger since co-hosting
ET in February you're taking a dog home
aren't you
I want this one because he looks like me
we went to rescue one of them it was our
day we were coming to pick him up
another family had not taken his sister
and she was left behind and I was like
no dog behind so we came home with both
of them so this is Jun the sister let me
hear them Benny my adopted
[Music]